pat 40 from sports illustrated senior
writer pat
thanks for joining us let me start with
the big ten what changed in the last
what month three weeks
yeah you know i think it was a
combination of things dan i mean you
start with
a the tangible advances in
rapid testing uh and everything that
that could do for you and i think that
really quite ironically the
the pac-12 commissioner larry scott when
he announced that the pac-12 had an
agreement with quiddell for
rapid daily testing all of a sudden the
big ten's like hey we'll go get that
and we'll do it faster and i think that
was the big thing but there's no doubt
that watching everyone else play
football
and hearing the outcry that was
associated with that watching the nfl
watching other college teams watching
high school teams play
and everybody's saying why are we
playing that i think that just kind of
wore down the resistances of the
big ten presidents what could go wrong
here yeah
well plenty um you know for one thing
there is a gap between when
rapid daily testing is supposed to start
and when practice is ramping up
at least two weeks here so you may see a
a higher degree of positives there
however they are not starting games
until october 23rd 24th
so there is a gap there a bit of a
cushion there where those people if you
do have spikes
could be okay but by the time they start
kickoff
but uh you know i mean just in general i
think you're going to be looking at a
campus
camp a little bit of campus unrest in
some of these places where like hey
we are going to these incredible efforts
for the football players
what about the regular students what are
we doing for them in terms of testing
and safety for them i know they uh it
was announced that it was a unanimous
vote
i would i would love to get the
backstory i'm trying to get the
backstory
of how much arm twisting went on because
i was told rutgers
and northwestern were not they went
kicking and screaming and i'm sure
there's probably a couple other schools
here
yeah i i don't think there's any
question that there were probably at
least three four maybe even five schools
that were not
on board rutgers the most obvious i mean
the president came out uh
all of a week earlier and said basically
what are we doing here
uh northwestern their president deserves
an academy award if he was not on board
because what he had to say on the uh
on the conference call yesterday was
basically that yes i'm on
i'm i'm okay with all of this in the
background he's probably rolling his
eyes significantly well now what's this
mean for the pac-12 they're on the clock
sure are and it's amazing though boy i
mean like once a domino falls
everybody else starts getting in
position to make the next domino fall
uh pac-12 presidents meeting on friday
i think to see if they can get a
consensus to
go ahead and move forward with
formalized practices
uh getting the politicians in california
and in oregon
the states that have been the most
restricted to lift some of the
restrictions and allow
11 on 11 practices yet that came
yesterday that was big and so now you
try to get the whole league on board and
you know the last i heard they're trying
to shoot for a halloween kickoff
and see how many games they can get in
uh and you got the mountain west
like what are what are the odds that the
mountain west comes back but the pac-12
does not come back
i don't think that will happen and i
think that those two will probably
both do the same thing uh a lot of
schools in the same states there
the california schools are up against it
as well in the mountain west and
you know the one other factor here those
wildfires
have made life very difficult out there
uh you know i've got a daughter swimming
at stanford they haven't been able to
get in the pool for a week because of
the air quality you're not going to be
able to practice football for
while the air quality is like that
either so there's a lot of other
considerations that still have to go
into this
what did you make of ed orgeron lsu head
coach
saying basically all my players have you
know tested positive
yeah uh that was coach oh being
perhaps more forthright and less
intelligent than he should be
in both instances uh i mean i i don't
think there's any doubt that there are
coaches out there that have that
mentality
of like let's just get our own little
hurt immunity and go for it
but from a public health standpoint i i
mean if you're like the public health
officials in baton rouge you've got to
be just
banging your head against the wall
saying what is this guy
doing as far as on the field here
is clemson by far and away the team to
watch out for
that we've seen play so far yeah i think
so i was at notre dame's game against
duke and
i mean they were okay um it was first
game again
it's going to take a while to really
figure out who's got what because it's
been such a ridiculous off-season
but on paper and i think from what they
showed for three quarters
on saturday clemson definitely is the
team now we'll see
starting october 23rd 24th what ohio
state looks like
uh before that on september 26th we'll
start seeing what alabama looks like
georgia looks like but clemson right now
yes
yeah and i'm also wondering about this
if you're playing less games and i was
told
by a source that ohio state is hoping
to pass the site test that the voters
are going to look and go you know they
didn't play as many games
but they look like they're a final four
team i think
i think that's the hope for the big ten
that ohio state if they're the ones that
get in
absolutely this is going to be the most
subjective
uh college football playoff committee uh
rankings ever
because you're going to have exactly
that you're going to have people's i
mean think about this
when the uh when ohio state finally
kicks off
uh alabama will have played like four or
five games
uh clemson will have played like seven
uh cnn six i mean they
see you're gonna be trying to look at
those teams and say and compare this
team over here
and to decide who should be ahead of
whom it's it's going to be
the most controversial the most messy
and the most subjective playoff rankings
ever
give me the team that could crash the
party
well you know i like oklahoma state from
that standpoint uh you know they
they have a ton of talent mike gundy was
completely off as rocker in the off
season but if he hasn't lost his
locker room they've got the number one
returning rusher in the country chuba
hubbard a 2 000
yard guy they've got a great receiver
tylan wallace who
missed most of last year with the knee
injury they've got a returning
quarterback with experience and they've
got 10 starters back on defense
uh i think they could challenge oklahoma
and if they you know the winner of the
big 12 figures to probably get a spot
depending what happens in these other
leagues i don't know how many times you
saw
lamar jackson play you're in louisville
but you know we
there were concerns with teddy
bridgewater and then there were concerns
with lamar jackson
how surprised are you with lamar
jackson's success
uh yes and no i mean i like i mean you
want to talk about intangibles that guy
a leader a team first guy fearless
tough dedicated he had all of those the
and then you had the athleticism it's
just you know
outrageous i mean that level of athlete
that even in the nfl is rare
i was not sure he had necessarily
command of the offense pocket passing
but he's shown that
excellently so far so i'm really happy
for him to see it because this is a
great guy and a great
team leader so what he's doing has been
outstanding yeah it's a great story as
well
uh are you off to any place this weekend
i'm not uh
the schedule's lousy uh so i will be
watching from home and uh monitoring all
developments
all right well thank you pat as always
great stuff uh throughout this
whole process there thanks for joining
us thank you dan that's pat 40. by the
way
turned 56 yesterday happy birthday pat
happy birthday